Salut, on est en plein dans les énigmes de l'été
tout les jours je vous donne une énigme
mais le lendemain je vous donne une nouvelle énigme avec la solution de l'énigme de la veille
et je vais commencer par vous donner la solution de l'énigme d'hier
donc si vous l'avez pas vu, aller vite la voir parce que là je donne la solution.
La réponse à la question d'hier était : Un cercueil.
L'objet dont je parlais était un cercueil !
Celui qui me fabrique me vend
celui qui m'achète ne se sert pas de moi, on se sert pas d'un cercueil
mais celui par contre qui se sert de moi ne le sait pas...forcément on sait pourquoi !
Après, si c'est un vampire forcément, ça marche pas pour l'énigme
mais on considère que bon c'est pas un vampire.
Oh c'était pas l'énigme la plus joyeuse, mais je la trouvais intéressante quand même.
Rassurez-vous l'énigme d'aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus joyeuse !
Trouvez la suite logique à ces lettres: U D T Q C
Aller je vous en rajoute une en bonus: S
Pour info c'est pas vraiment un indice, mais cette suite là est infini.
Je pourrais la continuer indéfiniment
Y'a une logique entre chaque lettre
A vous de la trouvez !
Quel sera la prochaine lettre après le S ?
N'hésitez pas à en parler dans les commentaires, mais ne donner pas la réponse
si vous avez la bonne réponse mettez un pouce en l'air comme ça, on sera le nombre de personne qui a trouvé la réponse
ou alors dans les commentaires vous pouvez mettre "Moi je sais" et vous mettez votre pouce !
L'intérêt étant de laisser les autres chercher jusqu'à demain
puisque que la réponse je vous la donne demain
dans le prochain MentalVlog à 17h avec la nouvelle énigme !
Profitez bien du soleil et rendez-vous demain
Ciao !